مبكرا احتاجت روسيا الى تعزيز قوتها
المحاربه في اوكرانيا بوحدات قتاليه
مسانده غير نظاميه وقد تسلطت الاضواء
اساسا على ميليشيا فاجنر بقياده
التي ادارت الهجوم الطويل على مدينه
باخموت الاوكرانيه ومع انتهاء مهمه باخطاع
المدينه في العشرين من ايار مايو الماضي
استعادت كتائب اخرى حالفه للجيش الروسي
بعض الاضواء مع تقارير عن انها ستخلف
مجموعه فاجنر يتعلق الامر بما يسمى قوات
احمد او مفارس اخماد التي اعلن الرئيس
الشيشاني رمضان قادروف تشكيلها في حزيران
يونيو العمل الماضي واعطاها اسم والده
احمد قديروف الذي كان احد زعماء الشيشان
قوات احمد قوامها عشره الاف مقاتل مقسمين
الى اربع كتائب عسكريه هي احمد شمال واحمد
جنوب واحمد شرق واحمد غرب يراس تلك القوات
الجنرال على الدينوف وهو مساعد للرئيس
الشيشاني كان قد تعرض في شوط فبراير
الماضي لمحاوله اغتيال فاشله بالسم تتسلح
قوات احمد باحدث الاسلحه الروسيه واقواها
بما فيها الدبابات والمركبات التي تحمل
شعار حرف زاد وهو شعار القوات الروسيه في
اوكرانيا ميدانيا تنشط قوات احمد الخاصه
في منطقه دونيسك شرق اوكرانيا حيث شنت
هجمات على محور مارينكا وهي تستعد الان
للتعويض قوات فاجنر في مدينه ارتيوموفوسكي
الاوكرانيه مع بدء هجوم كييف المضاد
تحدث الاعلام الاوكراني مرارا عن تلك
القوات ووصفها بالوحدات المرعبه كما يقر
القاده الروس بصلابه المقاتلين الشيشان
وشراستهم ويزداد الرهان عليهم لاحداث تحول
في مسار الحرب
وبتوقيعها يوم الاثنين على عقد مع وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه يقضي بخضوعها لاوامر وزير
الدفاع تبدو قوات احمد اكثر انسجاما مع
المؤسسه العسكريه في موسكو وهي خطوه قد
تؤهلها لادوار قادمه ربما على حساب
ميليشيا فاجنر التي رفضت التوقيع وخاض
رئيسها في الشهور الاخيره سجالات كثيره مع
القياده العسكريه الروسيه